Here We Stand.
Behold Our Bounty!
Let It Be Written that DNews have the Family,
Duty, Honor to be the Light in the Darkness
-- Guys.The dire wolf.
It's real.
And Winter is Coming.
May the light of the seven shine upon you,
I'm Trace, thanks for tuning in to DNews!
If you're not familiar, in Game of Thrones,
the family symbol of many of the main characters
who've died thus far in the series -- spoiler
-- is a direwolf; a massive, intelligent species
wolf common in the wildlands north of the
Wall.
But, and this is just frickin' amazing…
The direwolf isn't entirely fictional!
As late as 12,000 years ago, right here in
the good old Americas, there were dire wolves.
Aaaaaand they might be coming back.
Okay, so the direwolf and the dire wolf are
two different things.
The one word direwolf is fictional, and two
word dire wolf or canis dirus was very real!
In the first season of the TV show, direwolf
pups are played by Northern Inuit Dogs, which
are bred to look like wolves.
In the later seasons the wolves were played
by actual wolves, because HBO does not do
half measures.
This is about the best we can do today, because
actual dire wolves are extinct.
The real life Canis dirus lived between 300,000
and 12,000 years ago, which, as it happens,
was the last time perpetual winter happened
for real.
Dire wolves evolved towards the end of the
Pleistocene epoch, the last great ice age,
when huge glaciers covered up to 30% of the
Earth’s surface.
At their peak, the ice sheets extended as
far south as what is now Kentucky and were
almost 4 kilometers thick.
This was the age of megafauna like mammoths,
giant condors, giant beavers, and giants sloths.
Pretty much everything had the word giant
in its name.
For warm blooded animals, being larger meant
retaining heat better, which was an advantage
during an ice age.
So combine giant prey with colder conditions
and you get a Red Wedding made in heaven for
bigger predators like dire wolves.
Dire wolves weren’t quite as huge as George
“valar morghulis” Martin makes them out
to be**.
An average dire wolf was about 80 cm tall,
the same height of modern gray wolves, but
they were 25% heavier, weighing up to 67 kilograms.
Their skulls were broader and had a large
crest down the midline that was a good anchor
point for their strong jaw muscles.
Because of that their bite is estimated to
be 29% stronger than a gray wolf’s, which
already has the largest bite pressure of any
living canid.
Dire wolves and gray wolves coexisted for
about 100,000 years, but the end of the pleistocene
was marked with a period of extinction that
wiped out three quarters of the large ice
age animals.
No one’s really sure why, it may have been
due to climate change or humans getting really
good at hunting or both, but suddenly all
those giant animals died out.
The dire wolves went the way of the wooly
mammoth and sabre-toothed cat and the Starks,
while their smaller, quicker, bigger-brained
cousins, the gray wolves, survived.
So, you can’t have a dire wolf as a pet
because their genetic lineage hit a dead end
and most of what we know about them comes
from the skeletons we’ve found in the La
Brea tar pits, where there were oodles of
dire poodles.
But one dog breeder is aiming to revive them,
or at least the fantasy version of them.
The Dire Wolf Project has been breeding larger,
long-lived dire wolf-alikes since 1988.
After spending 20 years Never Resting, and
breeding Alaskan Malamutes, German Shepherds,
Great Pyrenees, Anatolian Shepherd, and English
Mastiff together -- they created what they
called the American Alsatian a 59kg shaggy
dog.
Still 8 kilos lighter than a true canis dirus,
but still Growing Strong.
Dogs have been with humanity waaay longer
than we thought, but who actually domesticated
them?
Did we do it?
Or did dogs domesticate themselves?
-- Check out DNews Plus for a whole series
on the domestication of animals big and small
here.